There's no secret the great us
locomotive is working at full speed.
Okay.
Ten years of uninterrupted growth.
The North American economy is enjoying a
wonderful moments.
You had employment rate lines below four
percent is lowest level since the year
2000 and every month more than a 100,000
new jobs are created.
Salaries are also growing,
and then the last three years alone,
almost 8 million jobs have been created.
In addition,
industrial production and exports are at
historically high levels,
even in spite of their last stumbled,
the SNP 500 has exploded in recent
years.
The locomotive is absolutely soaring it,
but hold on a second because the US
economy has another face and it's a face
we've already spoken about here on
visual politic debut is the American
economy,
especially the government is addicted to
credit and debt that right.
You're saying September the 30th,
2018 marks the end of the federal
government's budget.
Yeah.
And here's a question for you.
Can you tell me how much the federal
debt increased by in this year alone?
Actually it's about $40,000
or what's your.
The onset is no less than one point
$3,000,000,000,000.
This amount surpasses the entire Mexican
GDP.
We are living on borrowed money,
borrowed time,
these hike interest rates,
clobber exports,
stumped,
investment,
killed jobs,
undermine growth.
She our kit and shrink our future.
It's time to ask why it is that we have
run up more debt in this country in the
last eight years than we did in the
previous 200 and to make sure it never
happens again.
I'm
worried about the federal government
here.
The economy is growing,
but the public deficit is out of
control.
By the way,
just in the last year with Donald trump
in the White House,
government spending grew by seven
percent and it looks like things are
going to get worse,
much worse.
Congress' budget office estimates that
if they stay on this path in less than
10 years,
interest payments alone will cost the
federal governments more than $900,
billion dollars every single year.
However,
the federal government isn't the only
debt junkie.
Listen to this,
the states,
the hidden debt let me grow as an income
in 2017.
Thirty nine of the 50 states that make
up the United States had surpluses.
That is they made more money than they
spent.
Yeah.
Years of adjusting.
Now,
the question that many governors are
asking themselves is,
well,
what's the best way to spend all of this
money?
And on top of that,
since 2010,
every state's collection has increased
by 40 percent.
So we're really not talking about just a
few cents out.
Finally,
states have resources to invest in
infrastructure,
education,
social services,
etc.
Then this might all sound pretty good
rice.
Well,
sadly The truth is a little different.
In fact,
it's actually quite a lot different.
You see,
in principle,
every state except for Vermont has to
have a balanced budget.
However,
despite this and all the parents
announced surpluses,
the truth is that all of the states
won't stop accumulating debt obligations
and liabilities of all kinds.
In fact,
nowadays every stage drags according to
the think tank.
Truth and accounting.
A heavy load of more than one point 5
trillion in unfunded debt is that the
vast majority,
no less than 40 of the 50 states,
don't have the resources to face all of
the commitments that they've gotten
themselves into.
Well,
hold on a second.
Yeah,
because how the hell can states
accumulate desk while their budgets are
balanced?
Well,
basically by doing all kinds of
accounting tricks after old politicians
and elected officials are most
interested in masking that figures and
spending every penny.
I mean if we're honest about it.
This is kind of how elections are won.
Did they say they use many tricks from
inflating income assumptions?
do you delaying bill payments,
but the most important trick of all is
one that has to do with pensions and
benefits for public employees when they
retire.
Yes.
AlloW me to explain.
In order to gain votes and get along
with union state,
governments tend to promise public
employees very good pensions as well as
lots of additional benefits of paul
never time
right.
Given how the pension system works in
the United States,
this assumes that each month state
governments have to contribute to the
amounts they committed to to a pension
fund,
so there's tomorrow.
all those public workers can collect the
pensions that they were.
However,
just for a second,
let's put ourselves in the place of the
politicians in charge of the state
government.
What if instead of depositing all that
money into a pension funds,
we invest in all kinds of public
spending programs.
That way we can finance and lots of
projects which will make us win lots of.
Oops,
okay,
so some of you mIght now be thinking,
in fact,
all of you are probably thinking,
well,
what's going to happen to all of those
employees when they start retiring and
claiming those pensions and those
benefits?
The how are they going to be paid?
And the answer is it doesn't really
matter it.
Remember you're a politician that's
going to be someone else's problem way
down the line.
You just need to worry about winning the
next election.
Well,
folks,
according to the data it really looks
like that is actually the thought that
many state politicians have.
Hat state and local governments made big
commitments,
particularly on pensions and retiree
healthcare,
but didn't adequately fund those
liabilities.
Mr.
Brennan,
a democrat and mayor of hartford in
total only regarding unfunded state
pensions,
the state debts already exceed
$800,000,000,000.
The big question is knowing how the hell
they're going to be able to cope with
this huge amounts of debt,
but of course not every state is the
same,
so listen up
best and worst.
If we think about it for a moment,
it's easY to understand.
Politicians have a gigantic incentive to
spend every last penny after all that
entire future depends on the next
election cycle.
That's why it's so important.
In fact,
it's absolutely essential to not only
have counterweights,
but also for civil society to be
attentive and very demanding.
But let's go back to the case of the
United States.
As we've seen,
they aren't dragging a colossal unfunded
debt of one point $5,000,000,000,000.
However,
not every state is in the same
situation.
Out of the countries 50 states,
at least 40,
don't have enough assets today to face
all of their obligations.
Of course,
though some states are better off than
others.
In any case,
there are 10 states where politicians
have been responsible enough to
guarantee their state's future and keep
their accounts in order.
Well,
these are the 10 states that really did
their homework and we think they've
earned the right to actually get a
mention.
It would be Alaska,
North Dakota,
Wyoming,
Utah,
South Dakota,
Idaho,
Tennessee,
Nebraska,
Oregon,
and Iowa.
As you can see,
almost all of them,
with the exception of Oregon and Iowa
are strongly republican states and
democrats should really start looking at
it.
Yes.
The fact is that all the other states
currently haVe a negative balance,
of course,
to get a better idea of what we're
talking about.
Let's take a look a the following graph.
This shows the top five and bottom five
states.
Data is expressed in dollars per
taxpayer and yep,
you are looking at it right.
While states such as North Dakota,
Wyoming,
and Iowa,
I've been responsible and have
accumulated enough savings to meet all
of their obligations and even have
surpluses to invest in benefit each
state.
Illinois,
Connecticut,
and New Jersey dragging a terrifying
load of more than $58,000
per taxpayer.
Of course,
at this point,
the question is,
well,
how enough,
uh,
all the states going to be able to cover
their obligations.
The answer isn't simple because the
situation of some states as we saw in
the case of Illinois,
Connecticut and New Jersey is so bad,
but finding a solution is really hard.
Check this out.
In new jesse's case,
wHich is the worst off of all the
states,
the fiscal hold amounts to almost
$200,000,000,000.
That is to say this whole,
which belongs to a state that has a
little over 9 million inhabitants,
is larger than the economy of Qatar and
almost as big as the economies of
countries like New Zealand or Peru.
it's pretty damn crazy.
In any case,
what we can say is that ultimately there
are only two possible ways to solve
this.
Either they raise taxes or cut spending.
The problem is that raising taxes may
not even be an option because it can
damage the state's economic potential
and drive away taxpayers,
especially those who have large
fortunes.
That's precisely what happens in
Connecticut where in recent years a lot
of big businessmen have fled the state
because of high taxes in comparison to
other territories within the us,
and it wasn't only Connecticut in 2016,
the last year for which we have data.
600,000
people moved from the 25 states with the
highest access to the 25 states with the
lowest taxes and also donald trump's
latest fiscal reform at really looks as
if this process is going to speed up,
but that's something we're going to talk
about in a future video so far.
You can see that the debt addiction is
far from being an elusive federal
government problem.
The us economy is going strong,
but this is the other side of the coin.
The truth is that for the country's
growth to remain sustainable,
both the federal government and the
state governments need to finally start
taking the whole deficits and public
debt issue very seriously.
It is not normal for a country with such
a high amount of growth to have assumed
many public accounting balances and this
leads to big questions like what's going
to happen when it all goes wrong and
what's the limit to having so much debt?
Because folks,
let's not forget,
sooner or later in one way or another,
public debt always has to be paid.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos.
Also,
do not forget to check it off.
Friends at reconsider media.
They provided the vocals in this episode
that weren't on mine.
Also,
this channel of course is possible
because of patrons and our patrons on
that platform.
Please consider joining them in
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage,
and as always,
I'll see you in the next week.
What's your thinking.